thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air I'm gonna go out
on a limb and say when hundreds of Klu
Klux Klan members show up to your trial
it's probably a good idea to grant the
motion for change of venue
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer welcome back and welcome to my
new set which fun fact it's actually not
a new set it's just against a different
wall in my office but now with a hundred
percent more lamps so welcome today we
are covering a time to kill the classic
legal thriller starring Matthew
McConaughey and samuel l.jackson I've
actually never seen this movie before
despite lots of people recommending it
to me I think I was a little young when
this came out so it's going to be a
treat for me to watch this I'm expecting
a lot of courtroom theatrics and a bunch
of constitutional questions based on the
description of the movie as always be
sure to comment in the form of an
objection which I will either sustain or
overrule and stick around until the end
of the video where I give a time to kill
a grade for legal realism so without
further ado let's dig in to a time to
kill
Hey
she looks a little young
oh this okay I'm going to refrain from
showing you the graphic images in this
particular part of the movie but I think
it's going to set up the rest of the
narrative it looks like these two
southern boys have sexually assaulted
the daughter of samuel l.jackson and
then attempted to kill her so I think
that that sets up the legal premise of
the show but for the sake of being safe
for work I'm going to refrain from
showing you those images but just know
that that happens and is important for
the story
how many employments do we have today at
home not one but it is the first month
again and guess what well the checks are
pouring in we have enough money to pay
all our past debts and then so it'll be
your last drink just keep us no more
than one month behind on any wind or
please you have been drinking two months
well the leaves are the most delinquent
the rents in there
I appreciate the practice Catholic town
I do which you could have left me a
couple of clients this is actually
really interesting because the economics
of being a solo practitioner is
something that you don't really see a
lot in movies here you can see Matthew
McConaughey is struggling to meet his
bills and to pay his vendors was
obviously very important when you're
running your own business but when you
are the only attorney in your law firm
you live and die by not only having
clients but having clients that pay so
it's actually very common for solo
practitioners to get behind on their
bills because not only do the clients a
ban flow but also the clients ability to
pay changes over time that's why a lot
of law firms of the size and even bigger
law firms will get what's called a line
of credit which is a revolving loan that
allows them to meet their debts in lean
times and then pay it off when the
clients come back because obviously you
don't have to shut your doors just
because the clients have dried up for a
small amount of time and Matthew
McConaughey in this particular scene is
dealing with the economics of being a
small practitioner will need to come
with me hey you know I'm you know a
little girl you took four round
poor little girl I got bad news so
you've given Tracy didn't die so unless
there's another ridden I guess or got a
souped-up yellow pickup with a
confederate flag in the windshield hey
blue gums why don't you take your cold
black ass out of here and grab a branch
unless you got a nation for what this
was doing in the bed of your truck you
going to jail again so this is obviously
very dramatic and probably important for
the story when the police have probable
cause to arrest an individual who's
suspected in a capital offense a felony
like this there's no reason to engage in
any kind of pleasantries or engage in
any conversation they're going to arrest
these two guys so there's no point in
having a conversation with them the
proper procedure here would have been to
avoid the conversation go straight to
arresting them assuming that they have a
verified ID of these two guys and then
give them a Miranda warning so that
whatever they say can be used against
them at trial right now since the police
officer has not administered a Miranda
warning the statements of these
individuals can't be used against them
and won't be admissible in court so
there's really no point in taking out
your anger against these guys just
follow proper procedure give them a
Miranda warning arrest them and then get
their confessions I mean he always had
the right to remain silent you know the
police can get in really big trouble
here because the kind of force that they
used was completely unnecessary it was
sure provoked by the statement of the
individual but the police just can't use
this kind of overwhelming force just
because they don't like what this person
has said especially when they haven't
given this person a Miranda warning so
it can be very satisfying I'm sure to
beat the crap out of these guys who are
clearly very very bad people but that's
why we have rules that apply to everyone
regardless of how you personally think
about these defendants that's the point
of our judicial system so the police
really should have administered the
Miranda warning they should not have let
this situation escalate
that's not in anyone's interest and you
can get a Fourth Amendment violation
when you use this kind of force
unnecessarily neither not good police
procedure are you Carly Hailey's
attorney sir you mr. Hailey's attorney
yes I am I mean it should have been up
to the same a little Jackson to
determine if Matthew McConaughey's is
attorney or not you can't just walk
outside and decide that he's a the
attorney all right first things first
Braganza will file for a change of venue
I'd be a fool if they did it why is that
why should we tell our young uninformed
law clerk the reality of just prudence
in this county Evelyn give me the state
file on race statistics Taylor it's
quite simple this County's 26 30 percent
black give or take almost every other
County is a forty forty-five in some
cases seventy percent black blacks are
more sympathetic to other blacks he gets
it moved he has a greater chance of
color in the jury box and we know what
that means if the trial stays here it's
an all-white jury for sure now Taylor
this is for you
to integrate your brain with before
three o'clock tomorrow afternoon yes he
means we're not blacks on the jury
Hali hadn't got a chance in hell okay so
some of that makes sense some of that is
constitutionally infirm in this
particular case a change of venue is
probably warranted because this
particular community is going to have
lots and lots of opinions and
potentially a lot of prejudice about
this particular case because it's going
to be in the news it's going to be a hot
topic now one racial issue that this
prosecutor has mentioned that is a big
problem is he says that this community
is 30% african-american but he's going
to get an all-white jury a jury is
supposed to be an accurate reflection of
the community and if you start picking a
jury that does not reflect the community
in that way you're likely to run into a
constitutional challenge that may be
what this prosecutor wants but that's
not the way the system is supposed to
work and it may present an appealable
issue even if he were able to secure a
guilty verdict at trial the appeals
court might overturn on the grounds that
it's constitutionally
Natick all right noose is up for reelect
November good reach out to our friends
in the legislature have them call on
judge news we're just gonna help him
decide to keep this case in Canton also
oh my god okay so whatever it is he's
drinking these days dilution wheel banks
I believe that's do it I'll keep that
old drunk on the sidelines yeah okay
that is definitely prosecutorial
misconduct there is no way that the
prosecutor can call friends of the judge
and ask those friends to influence the
judge in a sitting case that is
completely improper that is basically
bordering on bribery to ask the judges
friends to intervene with the judge
engage in ex parte communications with
the judge to influence his decision on a
pending capital murder case that is
definitely something that the court of
appeal would look at if evidence ever
came out about that I think the Court of
Appeal would overturn this decision like
that and on top of that I think that the
prosecutor would be in real trouble with
the Ethics Committee of the State Bar I
think that this is exactly what the
ethics rules are intended to prevent and
luckily this kind of thing doesn't
happen very often in real life it does
unfortunately happen but the prosecutor
should know better that's completely
improper that should never happen what
do you think of mr. Brigance if that boy
still in law school say any husband for
me that's all
all right so there's the courtroom so
this particular courtroom looks like
they basically just reuse the set from
To Kill a Mockingbird which is to say
that this is not a realistic looking
courtroom there are courtrooms that
exist that look like this but for the
most part they're used solely for
ceremonial purposes they are not used
for active capital murder cases this
actually would be not a particularly
good courtroom to try a case it's huge
you know you've got a lot of distance
between all the different witnesses and
the judge it's actually just difficult
to be heard in a courtroom like this
it's really impractical for trying an
actual case now new selects this panel
at random if we get too many bad
candidates upfront were sunk luck of the
draw well you need is young fathers who
want to do what Carly Haley did agreed I
think we need young men with families
here now I would prefer no one over 50
less bigotry has a role with youth so we
stay away from women rednecks and old
men so they are planning what's called
voir dear which is the system by which
you choose the members of the jury that
will form the jury at trial you have a
large panel many of you have probably
served on jury duty so you've seen this
process in action you start with a large
panel and then you whittled that down
for various reasons you are allowed to
have what are called peremptory strikes
which gives you the ability to strike a
juror for any reason whatsoever and
you're also given strikes that allow you
to remove a member of the jury or the
potential member of the jury for cause
you demonstrate to the judge that they
are so prejudicial that they cannot
issue a fair verdict often the judge
will use his or her own discretion to
remove those people from the jury panel
themselves and the neither the
prosecutor nor the criminal defense
attorney have to use a strike to get rid
of that person but with peremptory
strikes you are allowed technically to
remove people for any reason whatsoever
there are limits to that power but
practically speaking that's what you do
to try and get a jury that is favorable
to your side as opposed to the other
side of course both the prosecution and
defense are both using the same tools
the peremptory strikes to try and get
the jury
that they want citizens vanity the
council each have 12 challenges let's
begin the 12 challenges would be
peremptory strikes you know the state
challenge is jus number 6:10 cochise
okay what the movie is hinting at here
is that the prosecutor played by Kevin
Spacey is striking all of the
african-americans from the jury you're
not allowed to do that now it's true
theoretically speaking that you can use
a peremptory challenge to get rid of
anyone that you want however there are
constitutional limits to that in 1986
the US Supreme Court in the case of
Batson versus Kentucky held that a
prosecutor cannot use his or her
peremptory strikes to strike all of the
members of one race from a jury without
stating a valid reason for each of the
individual members who were struck from
that jury that's exactly what Kevin
Spacey is doing here he said so earlier
in the movie that he was going to do
that and here he's trying to strike all
of the African Americans from the jury
that is constitutionally infirm under
the sixth amendment under the Batson
versus Kentucky case and I think that
that's a slam dunk on appeal I've
thoroughly reviewed your brief
requesting that they change the video
and our agreements with God I think it's
impossible to find a fair and impartial
jury here in Canton in fact I think it's
impossible to find a fair impartial jury
anywhere in Mississippi and as such jury
here would be as fair as a jury anywhere
else oh boy I've decided to deny your
request for a change of venue I think
the judge here is probably wrong doesn't
seem like he's really considered the
evidence or the situation at at bar the
city is at a boiling point there are Klu
Klux Klan members protesting everyday
that seems really really prejudicial and
there are probably parts of the state
where you could move this case and get a
more impartial jury that hasn't heard as
much as everyone in this community has
so on top of the entire conversation
being improper I think the decision that
the judge has made
is wrong whether that rises to what's
called an abuse-of-discretion which is
this generally the standard on appeal
when the appeals court is reviewing the
lower court's decision I don't know but
the judge is just wrong here and given
the impropriety it's probably going to
be overturned
[Applause]
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say when
hundreds of Ku Klux Klan members show up
to your trial it's probably a good idea
to grant the motion for change of venue
chef's if you would you please identify
this weapon
it's a weapon found at the scene and
were you able to identify any of the
fingerprints found on this gun yes
prints on the gun matched those of Carl
Lee hailey you're sure yes
yeah I'll not like to enter this into
evidence is exhibit s18 we have no
further use of this witness a couple of
problems of what just happened here
talking about the murder weapon in this
criminal proceeding number one again
this testimony may not be relevant
because I'm not sure it goes to the
state of mind of the defendant number
two if you were handling a physical
object where fingerprints were important
it would be wrapped in plastic in a
sealed plastic bag you wouldn't be
handling it yourself in court also you
would probably not want to bring in m16
into the actual courtroom with a
magazine attached to it you can just use
pictures and enter those into evidence
on top of that what the prosecutor
really should be doing here is not just
identifying that this weapon was used to
kill the two victims but what is
relevant to state of mind is the fact
that the same well Jackson had to get
that weapon you know out of his gun safe
and he had to load the magazine and he
had to put the magazine into the gun he
had to then sneak into the courthouse
hide all of these things show
premeditation and cognizance of what's
going on to counteract the defense of
insanity that is what this prosecutor
should be showing that the defendant
knew what he was doing and isn't legally
insane it's not just that he used a gun
to kill people that actually supports
the defendants side what he needs to do
is negate that and talk about a state of
mind or at least show the things that
demonstrate the state of mind of the
defendant he's not doing that and as a
result he is not preventing the defense
from using their insanity plea did you
arrest Billy Ray Cobb and Pete Willard
yes I did I arrested them for the rape
and attempted murder
of ten-year-old Tanya hailey and is it
true that people will 'red signed a
written confession saying that he and
Billy Ray Cobb did rape Tanya Haven
Jackson Your Honor that's inadmissible
and mr. Brigance and knows it
mr. Brigance I've spoken to you before
we are not trying to reap them miss
hailey today but the murder of two young
men and if you continue in this
performance I'll hold you in contempt
okay the prosecutor was way way late in
objecting if that isn't admissible then
he should have objected to the fact that
the policeman arrested the two men
before it's not just the confession but
all of the evidence of bad acts that
would be inadmissible but as I pointed
out before number one I think it is
admissible because it goes to the state
of mind of the defendant what he thought
those people did and again ironically
it's the prosecution then we want that
information in it shows that the
defendant acted in a premeditated way
because of the sexual assault of his
daughter so I am skeptical that number
one that information isn't admissible
and number two it's the prosecution that
would want that in in this courtroom so
it's some weird perverse arguing here my
name is dr. Wilbur
rodeheaver chair of psychiatry at
Mississippi State University and
clinical director of the Whitfield
facility for the criminally insane
Thank You dr. your credentials speak for
themselves no they don't
okay when you are trying to use expert
testimony on the stand it is very very
important to bolster that witness's
credibility
often you will spend half an hour 45
minutes an hour just going over the
credentials of your witness to
demonstrate that your witness is
entirely credible and that their opinion
is based on science and experience in
the federal court systems you go through
what's called the Dalbert standard for
ensuring that your witness meets the
standard for admissible evidence and
being able to opine because regular
witnesses lay witnesses are not allowed
to offer their opinion they are only
allowed to talk about what they actually
saw themselves and what's within their
own
personal experience experts on the other
hand are allowed to offer their opinion
that is what they are there to do is to
give you their scientific opinion based
on the evidence that you put before them
so it is incredibly important to make
sure that not only you demonstrate the
foundation that your witness your expert
witness knows what they're talking about
but that their their credentials really
are impeccable and simply stating that
your expert psychologist is in fact a
psychologist is not gonna get it done
number one that doesn't demonstrate to
the judge that their opinion is valid
and number two it doesn't show to the
jury that they should trust this person
and as this movie has pointed out
credibility of an expert opinion is very
very important now doctor can you please
explain as you do so eloquently in your
book the McNaughton rule for the jury
certainly the McNaughton rule states
that the person must be unable to tell
right from wrong and/or be unaware of
the consequences of his actions to be
termed legally insane okay that is
actually a reasonably good statement
about what the McNaughton rule is now a
couple problems with that number one
that's a legal standard so it's not
really up to the expert psychologist to
opine as to the ultimate issue about
whether the defendant meets the legal
standard for legal insanity that's where
the lawyers to do based on the witness's
testimony about their opinion about the
mental state the bigger problem is that
no one has used the McNaughton rule in
60 years
the McNaughton rule actually is based on
English common law in the 1850s where
someone attempted to kill the British
prime minister well McNaughton tried to
kill the British prime minister he
missed and killed the prime minister's
secretary a man named Peel I believe now
based on the circumstances I think it
was the court of Exchequer said that
McNaughton was legally insane and could
not be found guilty as a result he was
then put in
a insane asylum for the rest of his life
most US courts replaced the McNaughton
rule in the 1950s with what's called the
Durham rule and at least regarding
federal courts in the 1980s the Durham
rule was replaced with a definition of
insanity laid out in the comprehensive
Crime Control Act of 1984
so the McNaughton rule hasn't been used
in a very very long time in most
jurisdictions now the defense has to
prove insanity by clear and convincing
evidence which is a very high standard
it's not quite as high as beyond a
reasonable doubt but it's still a very
high burden to demonstrate that the
defendant at the time of the alleged
wrongdoing did not understand the nature
or quality of his or her actions and did
not understand the wrongfulness of the
Act so it's a much higher standard than
that laid out in McNaughton doctor who
do you work for state of Mississippi
you're 11 years working for the state
how many times have you testified in
trials where the insanity defense was
used this is my 46th trial 46 child well
of those 46 trials how many times you
testified that the defendant was legally
insane objection your honor
the good doctor cannot be asked to
recall all of his testimony these
previous trials it's absurd overruled
yeah that's a really bad objection one
of the most common questions you will
get as an expert witness is how many
times you've testified how many times
you've testified for one side versus how
many times you've testified on the other
because people know that there are
experts that are going to testify on
behalf of the defendants or largely on
behalf of the prosecution often a good
witness will intentionally have cases
where they have testified on either side
purposefully to avoid seeming biased in
this kind of context where you have only
testified for one side instead of the
other I can't remember
could it be doctor that the reason you
can't remember is that in eleven years
and forty six trials you never have seen
a defendant whom you have found insane I
can't recall it this time
that's another way to screw up your
testimony
is to say that you know definitively
that you've testified 46 times but you
can't remember how many times you voted
on the other side that's opening
yourself up to cross-examination and
destroying your credibility as an expert
witness you you don't do stupid things
like that you never have seen a
defendant whom you have found insane I
can't recall it this time can you recall
testifying at the trial one dan Baker
objection your honor this has nothing to
do with the proceedings here thank you
your honor
this better be good is not a reason to
overrule someone's objection the
prosecutor should have stated his
grounds for objecting and gotten a
response from Matthew McConaughey but
yeah there is no legal standard that
evidence can come in if it's going to be
good doesn't work that way in 1985 you
testified that Dan Baker was legally
sane the jury disagreed with you and mr.
Baker was found not guilty by reason of
insanity since that time he has been a
patient in your hospital under your care
as a paranoid schizophrenic is that
correct doctor yes do you normally admit
patients keep and treat them for 10
years if they have sound mind and body
of course not it would be fair to say
that you find insane people saying for
the purposes of child objection your
honor this was argumentative yeah so
that is argumentative but the points
that he was making were perfectly valid
points and there's a good way to show
the bias of a particular expert in this
case Matthew McConaughey has done a good
job of impeaching this witness's
credibility by showing that he testified
previously that a man was legally sane
but then admitted that person to his
mental institution as an insane person
and has kept him there for over ten
years on the basis that he's insane and
that actually raises a really
interesting part of the insanity defense
most people get really upset when they
think about a murderer being found not
guilty by reason of insanity thinking
that they just go free they don't when
you
find someone legally insane they go to a
mental institution they do not go into
the public and it's true that there is
no set time that they have to be kept in
that mental institution but that really
cuts both ways
it's true that they can be let out
immediately upon finding that they are
legally sane but what happens most the
time is those people are kept in that
place for the rest of their lives and in
fact McNaughton who gave the name to the
McNaughton rule after he was found not
guilty by reason of insanity spent the
rest of his life in a mental institution
so don't think that just because someone
is found not guilty by reason of
insanity it means that they're going
scot-free in to the public at large on
the contrary they might spend more time
in a mental institution than they would
if they were found guilty of the
underlying crime mr. Haly before you
stepped outside of yourself to watch
yourself shoot mr. Willett and mr. Cobb
were you aware that if convicted they
might be freed in only ten years yes I
heard people say that yes goes to his
mental state No do you think two men who
rape a child should be free in ten years
it's starting to get child Jack's free
ten-year inject what do you think should
happen yeah so this is such an obvious
trope in legal dramas the prosecutor
doesn't get to do that you don't get to
slowly approach the witness as you're
asking more argumentative questions
after argumentative question number one
you don't get to enter the well like
that without permission the judge the
bailiff will tackle you on top of that
you don't get to raise your voice and
yell at the defendant and then get this
Perry Mason moment where the defendant
basically admits that he wanted to
premeditatedly kill someone like that's
that's not how these things work the
defendant has a Fifth Amendment right
not to take the stand and there is
nothing in that testimony that he just
said that helped his case and in fact I
think legally speaking he
that he had the mental state required
for murder and not the mental state
required for the insanity defense so
that's a classic reason why you don't
put a criminal defendant up on the stand
there's just no reason for it soaked in
her blood left to die
can you see you I want you to picture a
little barrel
now how imagine she's white okay that is
a very eloquent closing argument the
problem is that in closing arguments you
are not allowed to put improper emphasis
on the victims race historically it has
been the prosecution who has put too
much emphasis on the race of the victim
in order to drum up high emotions
against the defendant but I think the
same rule applies to the defense the
system is supposed to be colorblind
and the race of the victim here is not
strictly relevant as to whether or not
the defendant in this particular case is
more likely or not to have committed the
crime that he's accused of so I think
that that's probably an improper closing
argument to make and it is likely to be
an issue on appeal okay now it is time
to give a time to kill a grade for legal
realism this was a heavier movie than we
are used to dealing with on this series
but I think it's important to address
these dramas because these kind of
issues do show up in real-life
courtrooms from time to time and I would
be remiss not to talk about these
subjects and I think this movie does a
good job of talking about some issues
that you don't really see the economics
of being a solo practitioner the issues
of race that show up constantly in our
judicial system regardless of our
efforts to try and stamp those out and
even some technical things like the
McNaughton rule while it's not the right
standard it was the right standard at a
certain point in time and they did deal
with some of the nuance there
unfortunately the movie dealt a lot with
over dramatizations they left out a lot
of the proceedings that would normally
occur and often oddly the prosecution
was arguing a hundred percent the wrong
way they were arguing for things that
would help defense and the defense was
arguing things that would help the
prosecution so all in all I give a time
to kill a be - it
is definitely a worthwhile drama to
watch but some of the nuance is plainly
lost a time that kills shows us what
happens to our institutions when they
are at a breaking point
I'm currently enjoying a documentary on
how that kind of stress affects the
presidency on curiosity stream it's
called presidents in crisis it's a great
piece about how presidents Lincoln
Roosevelt and Johnson were all
transformed by personal trauma and how
that affected the way that they governed
if you're looking for the best
documentaries and nonfiction movies out
there you should definitely check out
curiosity stream legal eagles get a free
account for 31 days by clicking on the
link below or using the promo code legal
eagle so click on the link below check
out the greatest documentaries on the
planet and until next time I'll see you
in court